moskau die hauptstadt oslo
eine riesige metropole mit mehr als
zwölf millionen einwohnern
vernetzt durch ein beeindruckendes u
bahn system
bis zu neun millionen fahrgäste sind
hier jeden tag mit der metro unterwegs
sie gilt als die schnellste pünktlichste
und als eine der sichersten u bahnen der
welt
für die angestellten bedeutet dass jede
menge stress
[Musik]
in sekundenbruchteilen müssen sie die
richtigen entscheidungen treffen
bitte nutzen sie die rolltreppe nach
unten
die moskauer metro läuft so präzise wie
ein uhrwerk aber was spielt sich hinter
den kulissen ab
[Musik]
moskau am frühen morgen
die riesenstadt schläft nach
[Musik]
aber tief unter der erde erwacht die
metro bereits zum leben
das moskauer u bahn netz hat zwölf
linien mit 365 kilometern schienen und
212 stationen tendenz steigend
das gewaltige netzwerk wird von einem
kontrollzentrum im herzen der stadt aus
koordiniert
in knapp 20 depots sorgen techniker
dafür dass die gut 600 züge
einsatzbereit sind
eines der größten ist dass in china
36 züge stehen hier im depot
trotz der urzeit herrscht schon reges
treiben
die bahnen bedienen linie 7 die mit rund
eineinhalb millionen passagieren am tag
die meistgenutzte ist
fahrer pavel major of hat heute
frühschicht
in 45 minuten muss ich los
vor schichtbeginn muss sich jeder fahrer
medizinisch untersuchen lassen nur wer
absolut fit ist darf zum dienst antreten
irgendwelche beschwerden ein
wie lange ihre pause 19 stunden gut
nirgend sonst werden u bahn fahrer so
streng kontrolliert wie hier und das
zahlt sich aus
laut den betreibern gab es in den mehr
als 80 betriebsjahren keinen einzigen
unfall der vom fahrer verschuldet wurde
mario hoff hat den medizincheck
bestanden er bekommt seine route
zugewiesen
sie nehmen route 33 der zug steht auf
gleis 14 und ist einsatzbereit
gute fahrt
es ist jetzt 4 55 m 20 minuten muss
major auf unterwegs sein
als fahrer muss er sicherstellen dass
alles am zu einwandfrei funktioniert
der zug hat die systemprüfung beendet
alles in ordnung ich kann losfahren ich
muss nur die stromzufuhr einschalten und
auf grünes licht warten
im minutentakt verlassen die züge das
depot
vor mallorca fliegt eine acht stunden
schicht
er wird heute tausende fahrgäste von a
nach b bringen
in 15 minuten müssen die züge im
gesamten schienennetz bereit stehen dann
ist betriebsbeginn
ein wichtiger verkehrsknotenpunkt ist
die station komsomolskaja hier treffen
zwei hauptlinien aufeinander und die
station liegt zwischen drei wichtigen
fernbahnhöfen der hauptstadt
[Musik]
5 uhr 30 am eingang warten schon die
ersten fahrgäste
nach sind die stationen der metro
geschlossen die tore öffnet sich erst am
morgen wieder
wer mit der u bahn fahren will muss eine
der 3100 elektronischen zugangssperren
passieren jede fahrt kostet umgerechnet
rund 70 cent egal wie lang oder kurz
dann geht es erst mal runter
die moskauer metro ist eines der am
tiefsten liegenden u bahn netze der welt
die station komsomolskaja liegt 37 meter
unter der erde
als sie in den 50er jahren erbaut wurde
geizten die architekten licht mit prunk
[Musik]
die bis zu drei meter hohen mosaike
bestehen aus mehreren hunderttausend
steinen und stellen glorreiche momente
der russischen geschichte dar
[Musik]
jeden tag steigen hier mehr als 150.000
fahrgäste ein und aus
natalja gontscharowa ist diensthabende
station schiffes
ihre hauptaufgabe ist es die
menschenmassen zu dirigieren
[Musik]
meine arbeit ist eigentlich nicht
schwierig das wichtigste ist dass ich
zuverlässig und umsichtig bin hier ist
ja in eile ich muss dafür sorgen dass es
keine probleme gibt und immer aufmerksam
sein
der erste ansturm hat sich gelegt jetzt
kehrt etwas uhr ein bisschen gut einer
stunde die stoßzeit beginnt gontscharowa
nutzt die zeit für einen kontroll
rundgang alle betriebsräume müssen
abgeschlossen sein
gontscharowa überprüft jeden winkel
ihrer station und achtete dabei auch auf
potenzielle gefahren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier ist alles okay
[Musik]
die u bahn fühlt sich um die massen
abzufertigen fahren die züge alle 90
sekunden
fahrpläne braucht es also nicht eine und
zeigt an wie lange die letzte abfahrt
zurück liegt
in 99 9 prozent der fälle kommt die
nächste bahn pünktlich nach 90 sekunden
und das trotz der vielen fahrgäste damit
das so bleibt überprüft concha rover
regelmäßig die ablaufpläne
die züge sollen nicht länger als 30
sekunden in der station halten ich achte
darauf dass alles nach plan läuft und
habe natürlich ein auge auf die
fahrgäste
verspätet sich ein zug meldet
gontscharowa es sofort an die zentrale
in der moskauer innenstadt
hier laufen alle fäden zusammen
die 30 mitarbeiter dirigieren und
überwachen von hier aus das gesamte u
bahn netz
wenn bei disponent albert qureshi das
telefon klingelt bedeutet das meist
nichts gutes
[Musik]
ich sehe alle züge und stationen auf dem
monitor und kann die zugbewegungen mit
den ablauf plänen abgleichen
[Musik]
diese pläne helfen wir bei der
koordination
bei einer störung so wie jetzt gerade
gebe ich den fahrern auf der strecke
sofort neue anweisungen
ähnlich wie fluglotsen müssen
fahrdienstleiter all ihre züge ständig
im auge behalten nur so kann sie
rechtzeitig reagieren
ist eine bahn leicht verspätet weisen
sie den fahrer an die stopps an den
haltestellen zu verkürzen um zeit
gutzumachen
immer zwei disponenten sind für jede u
bahn linie zuständig das ist dem
einzigartigen aufbau der moskauer metro
geschuldet die 12 u bahn linien der
russischen hauptstadt sind völlig
unabhängig voneinander
jede linie hat ihr eigenes strecken
system mit eigenen stationen
urinieren aufeinandertreffen verlaufen
sie auf unterschiedlicher höhe das macht
fehleranfällige weichen systeme
überflüssig ist eine linie verspätet
werden die anderen davon nicht
beeinträchtigt
[Applaus]
trotzdem können jederzeit probleme
auftreten und da kommt die disponenten
ins spiel
[Musik]
ich arbeite seit anderthalb jahren als
disponent
das schwierigste ist ruhig zu bleiben
wenn ein zug liegen bleibt oder andere
zwischenfälle auftreten
gemeinsam mit anderen abteilungen
überwache ich die gesamte linie als
disponent muss sich ruhig und klar
bleiben und die richtigen anweisungen
geben sonst mache ich auch andere
nervöse
bisher hatte ich glück und musste mich
noch nicht mit ernsthaften
schwierigkeiten auseinandersetzen
das schlimmste war als einer der züge
einen defekt hatte und ich die abläufe
an das regel musste
die moskauer metro ist das meist
befahrene u-bahn-netz europas und dabei
macht sie auch optisch einiges her
die erste linie wurde 1935 eröffnet sie
war rund elf kilometer lang und verband
mit 13 stationen die damals wichtigsten
punkte der sowjetischen hauptstadt
[Musik]
wenig später wurden die ersten
abschnitte der linien 2 und 3 eröffnet
sogar während des zweiten weltkrieges
wurde weitergebaut
die metro ist seither immer weiter
gewachsen
in den kommenden jahren will die
russische regierung das streckennetz auf
insgesamt mehr als 450 kilometer länge
ausbauen
vorbilder für die moskauer metro sind
die u bahn netze in paris london berlin
und madrid
anfang der 30er jahre wurden sogar
arbeiter aus england für den bau
angeworben
das unterirdische streckennetz sollte
perfekt auf moskau zugeschnitten sein
das ziel war eine u bahn die nicht nur
besser ist als alle bisherigen sondern
die welt auch mit ihrer schönheit
beeindruckt
stalin beauftragte die besten
architekten und künstler der sowjetunion
mit der gestaltung der stationen nach
einer rekordbauzeit von nur rund drei
jahren oder am 15 mai 35 der erste
abschnitt eröffnet er verläuft direkt
unterhalb des stadtzentrums
bis heute gilt die moskauer metro als
schönste der welt
44 ihrer stationen wurden zu unesco
welterbe stätten erklärt
[Musik]
sie wirken beinahe wie paläste
ihre malereien mosaike und skulpturen
erzählen von den helden der sowjetunion
[Musik]
hunderttausende quadratmeter marmor
fliesen wurden verlegt
[Musik]
auch die neueren stationen können sich
durchaus sehen lassen
es ist kurz vor acht uhr
die russische hauptstadt ist der wacht
millionen menschen fahren zur arbeit
oder schule
nicht nur auf den straßen
[Musik]
sondern auch darunter ist die rush hour
in vollem gange
allein zur morgendlichen stoßzeit nutzen
rund zwei millionen menschen die u-bahn
an wochentagen sind es über den ganzen
tag verteilt etwa neun millionen
fahrgäste im jahr macht das rund
zweieinhalb milliarden
obwohl die u bahnen so dicht getaktet
fahren wird es eng in den wagen
[Musik]
während der rushhour kommen
durchschnittlich neun fahrgäste auf
einen quadratmeter
die station komsomolskaja ist ein
wichtiger knotenpunkt
inzwischen treffen immer mehr passagiere
von den umliegenden fernbahnhöfen 1
station scheffer natalia over muss nun
eingreifen und den strom der fahrgäste
lenken
eine sich diese blieben wieder so
[Musik]
sehr geehrte fahrgäste der ausgang
richtung stadtzentrum und zu den
bahnhöfen befindet sich mittig auf dem
bahnsteig bitte nutzen sie die
rolltreppe nach unten
mancher europa schließt den hauptausgang
bis jetzt konnten die fahrgäste die
station über den haupteingang betreten
und verlassen
in dem sie ihn als ausgang schließt
makarowa aus der station eine
einbahnstraße
wer raus will muss nun einen umweg über
die benachbarte station der roten linie
nehmen
die maßnahme zeigt wirkung die
aufgestauten massen fließen langsam
18 uhr schichtwechsel
concha rover hat für heute feierabend
ihre kollegin irina bokova löst sie ab
alle züge fahren planmäßig
keine störungen
irgendwas nein alles nach plan
hast du den schlüssel
für smalltalk bleibt keine zeit rund
30.000 fahrgäste steigen hier während
der morgendlichen rushhour in die metro
und station scheffel volvo war muss
sicherstellen dass dabei nichts schief
geht
[Musik]
ich achte auf ein- und aussteigende
fahrgäste darauf dass niemand in der tür
stecken bleibt und dass die türen
rechtzeitig schließen
macho war ist auch ansprechpartnerin für
fahrgäste
[Musik]
ihr voller es wird desto mehr probleme
und fragen kommen auf aber mich stresst
das eigentlich nicht man muss höflich
sein und die leute mit respekt behandeln
das klappt immer
die moskauer metro ist oft der
schnellste weg von a nach b in der
russischen metropole
auch für die fahrer sehr gebag media
ich habe eine bestellung für die
wolgograd ski prospekt mit dem auto 40
minuten die metro ist viel schneller
bach mädchen muss insgesamt sechs
stationen fahren und einmal umsteigen
unter seinen kunden zu kommen die fahrt
dauert nur 20 minuten
jeden tag denkt er während der arbeit
etwa 70 kilometer mit der metro zurück
sehr viel mehr als der durchschnittliche
fahrgast mit knapp 15 kilometern
nach vier minuten erreicht bach metav
seinen umsteigebahnhof
jetzt muss er gut 500 meter zur nächsten
bahn laufen mit der es dann weitergeht
[Musik]
danach sind es noch vier stationen
um den strom der fahrgäste zu
kontrollieren hat die metro an allen
umsteige stationen schilder leitsysteme
eingerichtet wer ihnen folgt hat gute
chancen sich in den menschenmassen
zurechtzufinden
[Musik]
fachmedien braucht sieben minuten für
den umstieg ein neues ticket muss er
nicht lösen seien es ist gültig bis er
die metro verlässt egal wie oft er
umsteigt
an der nächsten station werden
sitzplätze frei aber bach mädchen bleibt
stehen
die erhält man für senioren schwangere
und leute mit kindern frei
ich bleib lieber stehen
ein ungeschriebenes gesetz der
höflichkeit dass auch in der vollsten
u-bahn beachtet werden sollte
nach 19 minuten ist nach meter vom ziel
von hier aus ist es nur noch ein kurzer
fußmarsch bis zum kunden er kündigt sich
per telefon an
pro tag liefert er im schnitt sieben
bestellungen aus die erste ist gleich
erledigt
kurz nach 9 uhr
disponent albert chorischen hat in der
zentrale alle hände voll zu tun die
morgendlichen rushhour ist noch nicht
vorbei
disponent 34 80 ich höre der zug ist
eine station chemiker wieder im zeitplan
[Musik]
wie viel verspätung hat zug 1 93 auf
rote 78
einzug ist gerade vom plan abgewichen
fragt sich warum
viele verspätungen werden von den
fahrgästen verursacht das ein und
aussteigen dauert einfach zu lange
[Musik]
jetzt ist am meisten los es sind sehr
viele menschen unterwegs die züge fahren
in den kürzestmöglichen abständen das
macht die arbeit während der stoßzeiten
sehr stressig
kury sheen steht jederzeit mit allen
stationen und fahren seiner linie in
funkkontakt
er koordiniert acht stationen 14 züge
und 12.000 fahrgäste und zwar zur selben
zeit
verspätet sich eine bahn muss er gegen
maßnahmen ergreifen damit nachfolgende
züge nicht beeinträchtigt werden
bei problemen muss sich schnell
gegensteuern und umorganisieren damit
die metro weiter nach plan fährt
neben dem regulären verkehr müssen die
disponenten auch zahlreiche betriebs
fahrten koordinieren und die
diensthabenden station chefs über sie
informieren
gerade wurde ein zug angekündigt der
ohne halt durchfahren wird jetzt muss
ich an sagen dass die fahrgäste nicht
einsteigen könnte
volvo war muss sich beeilen schon bald
fährt der zug durch
[Musik]
sehr geehrte fahrgäste der nächste zug
der kurs kaya linie hält nicht an dieser
station bitte treten sie von der
bahnsteigkante zurück
ich muss darüber
boccia stellt sicher dass die fahrgäste
nicht zu nah an der bahnsteigkante
stehen
[Musik]
kurtzke
das war der disponent gleich noch ein
zug durch er ruft wir bestätigen die
information notieren die zeit und
überwachen dann die durchfahrt
um 10 uhr ist die erste stoß zeit des
tages überstanden jetzt
kambodscha anweisung geben den
haupteingang auch wieder als ausgang zu
öffnen und die rolltreppen in beide
richtungen fahren zu lassen
er lässt jetzt noch diese fahrgäste
durch sperrt dann den zugang und sobald
der letzte fahrgast runter ist lässt er
die rolltreppe in die andere richtung
fahren
geschafft
das fahrgastaufkommen hat sich wieder
normalisiert
die belegschaft hat die anspruchsvolle
stoßzeit ohne zwischenfälle gemeistert
um der steigenden zahl an fahrgästen
gerecht zu werden dort die stadt eher u
bahn netz immer weiter aus
alexejew ist einer der verantwortlichen
ingenieurs
per fahrstuhl geht es tief unter die
stadt
hier entsteht die zweite ringlinie der
moskauer metro
eine der neuen stationen liegt in 65
metern tiefe
[Musik]
medwedews team arbeitet bereits seit
anderthalb jahren dran in den kommenden
tagen soll der beton für den bahnsteig
und die treppen gegossen werden
danke
das wird mal der bahnsteig sein
fahrgäste die zur station sablowski ja
wollen gehen da lang
hiermit ich wird es einen ausgang zur
straße geben
und am ende des bahnsteigs entsteht ein
zweiter ausgang nach oben
schon in sechs monaten wird die station
eröffnet bis dahin haben medwedew und
sein team noch alle hände voll zu tun
da die u bahn strecke so tief verläuft
ist eine stabile tunnel aus kleidung
besonders wichtig
[Musik]
das metall muss ordentlich verschweißt
werden damit keine netze durchkommt
die schweißnähte sehen gut aus
der kunde wird zufrieden sein
[Musik]
das erdreich unterhalb der metropole
stellt die ingenieure vor ein problem
es ist von unterirdischen wasseradern
und weichen sedimentschichten durchzogen
deshalb muss das u bahn netz in so
großer tiefe verlaufen und das wiederum
erfordert einen speziellen aufbau
eine metrostation besteht aus drei
röhren die mittlere dient als bahnsteig
über
durchgänge ist sie mit den äußeren
röhren verbunden in denen die züge
fahren nur so kann die station dem druck
des über liegenden erdreichs standhalten
und
[Musik]
die tiefe bringt noch eine weitere
herausforderung mit sich tausende von
menschen müssen gleichzeitig runter zu
den zügen gelangen
das ist eine der ausgänge hoch zur
straße die rolltreppe hier wird 99 meter
lang sein
damit gehört sie zu den längsten der
welt
[Musik]
im gesamten moskauer u bahn system gibt
es weit über 700 rolltreppen
zusammen sind sie mehr als 30 kilometer
lang
nur 15 moskauer stationen kommen ohne
rolltreppe aus
[Musik]
um unfällen vorzubeugen ist eine
aufseherin eigens für die rolltreppen
abgestellt
carina kostbar macht diesen job seit
mehr als zehn jahren
es ärgert sie wenn manch einer meint sie
würde hier nur tatenlos herumsitzen
das ist kein leichter job denn es sind
menschen im spiel
ich überwache wie sich die fahrgäste auf
der rolltreppe verhalten es kann immer
etwas passieren
ich muss ständig aufmerksam sein damit
ich im notfall die rolltreppe
rechtzeitig anhalten kann ich achte
gleichzeitig auf den monitor und auf die
rolltreppe die leute haben kinder dabei
und gepäck hier sind auch fern bahnhöfe
und es sind einfach sehr viele menschen
unterwegs
um den andrang zu bewältigen haben die
rolltreppen der moskauer metro eine
besonderheit sie laufen fast doppelt so
schnell wie die in der eu mit 3,2
kilometern pro stunde
ich muss vor allem das ende der
rolltreppe im auge behalten jemand
könnte hängenbleiben oder kinder wollen
dort spielen da kann viel passieren es
ist gefährlich
vor einigen jahren wollte der staatliche
betreiber die rolltreppen aufseher durch
computer systeme ersetzen aber die
fahrgäste protestierten sie würden sich
dann nicht mehr sicher fühlen
mittagszeit in der moskauer metro
der diensthabenden station chefin irina
popova bleibt keine zeit zum durchatmen
kommen sie mosca ja ich höre
ich bin gerade unterwegs um die
betriebsräume zu überprüfen
einmal pro schicht moosburger koralle
betriebsräume checken
peter voser griff das hier ist der ball
ich stelle sicher dass alles in ordnung
und alles zugedreht ist
es ist wichtig dass die elektrischen
komponenten trocken sind und eine holz
unterlage haben damit niemand einen
stromschlag bekommen
alles ist in ordnung der hahn ist auch
die technik in diesem raum steht im
krassen gegensatz zu den modernen u bahn
und sicherheitssystemen aber dank
täglicher kontrolle und instandhaltung
funktioniert alles einwandfrei
horacio war muss auf alles ein auge
haben
in der station sind ständig
reinigungsteams im einsatz egal wie
viele fahrgäste hier unterwegs sind
alles soll immer sauber und ordentlich
sein
euro was runde führt sie an einer ganz
besonderen tür vorbei
mit dieser schweren stahltür hier können
wir im notfall den eingang verschließen
ich hoffe dass wir nie in so eine
situation kommt
dank solcher türen können die meisten
metrostationen auch als bunker genutzt
werden
und das geht zurück auf den zweiten
weltkrieg
[Musik]
da die stationen so tief im erdreich
liegen haben sie sich als schutzräume
bei luftangriffen angeboten
innerhalb weniger monate wurden die
stationen damals mit stahltüren
ausgestattet
[Musik]
als die stadt 1941 und 1942 von der
deutschen luftwaffe bombardiert wurde
fanden dort rund 500.000 menschen schutz
es gab konzerte filmvorführungen und
krankenstationen tief unter der erde
150 kinder kamen hier während des
krieges zur welt die metro war der
sicherste ort der stadt
einmal im jahr prüfen und warten
techniker alle schutztüren um
sicherzustellen dass sie sich im notfall
problemlos schließen lassen
selbst in neuen stationen werden solche
schutztüren installiert
die diensthabende station chefin barbara
ist immer noch mit ihrem kontrollgang
beschäftigt
ich mag meine arbeit sehr mir gefällt
dass sich dafür präzise zuverlässig und
pünktlich sein muss ich muss
gleichzeitig denken und handeln kopf
hände und füße alles muss parallel
funktionieren das mag ich
november ist für jeden winkel der 12.000
quadratmeter großen stationen
verantwortlich
der kontrollgang dauert eine stunde
[Musik]
suzuka ist alles in ordnung jeder macht
seine arbeit und alles ist wie es sein
sollte
jetzt kann sie sich eine kurze pause
genehmigen
13 uhr die innenstadt ist relativ ruhig
jetzt sind hauptsächlich touristen
unterwegs die meisten moskauer sind bei
der arbeit
u bahnfahrer pavel major beendet gerade
seine schicht bei diesem halt übernimmt
ein kollege
der fahrerwechsel dauert nur bereit sich
sie konnten länger darf der zug nicht
halten
ich habe jetzt feierabend
die schicht lief gut nur ein paar
kleinere probleme
zu den stoßzeiten haben es die leute
eilig und wollen bloß nicht zu spät
kommen aber ich habe es geschafft
alles gut gelaufen
[Musik]
major offs arbeitstag ist zu ende die
fahrer müssen mindestens zwölf stunden
pause zwischen ihren schichten haben
am anderen ende der stadt kümmert sich
lieber fahrer särge bach mädchen um die
nächste bestellung
der kunde hat essen aus einem restaurant
hier bestellt
das mädchen muss die bestellung durch
die halbe stadt bringen
für die strecke rechnet er mit maximal
30 minuten
[Musik]
auch jetzt ist die metrostation noch gut
gefüllt
diese bahn ist relativ neu und hat sogar
eine handy ladestation
das ist sehr praktisch
ich brauche mein handy ja für die arbeit
die fahrgäste können hier nicht nur ihr
handy laden es gibt auch gratis wlan in
allen zügen der moskauer metro
[Musik]
wissen
nach 15 minuten steigt massiv in eine
andere den jungen
mit der nächsten bahn hat er weniger
druck
[Musik]
diese züge sind sehr alt sie sind
unbequem und laut wenn ich telefoniere
verstehe ich so gut wie nichts
in den alten zügen sind fahrgäste einer
geräuschkulisse von bis zu 100 dezibel
ausgesetzt zum vergleich bei den
modernen sind es nur 55
ein paar minuten später hat macht sein
ziel erreicht
in der moskauer metro werten sechs
fahrzeugtypen eingesetzt unterschiedlich
alt und teilweise mit beeindruckender
lebensdauer
jede behandlung im jahr durchschnittlich
rund
180.000 kilometer zurück rechnet man die
fahrten aller züge zusammen kommt man
auf 108 millionen kilometer jährlich
2700 mal um die welt
gewartet werden die züge in den
verschiedenen depots
jedes ist auf einen bestimmten
fahrzeugtyps spezialisiert
an der station war die kino befindet
sich eines der größten bahn
ausbesserungswerk moskaus
die mechaniker warten und reparieren
hier bis zu 30 züge am tag
michaelskirche ist hier werksleiter bei
diesem wagen steht heute die
hauptleitung an
[Musik]
wir fangen jetzt mit diesem wagen an
wir bauen erst alles auseinander und
überprüfen
und dann überholen wir den motor und die
radlager
alle 560.000 kilometer also rund alle
drei jahre in immenstadt und sein team
jeden zug komplett auseinander
[Musik]
das ist anspruchsvolle arbeit aber wir
sind daran gewöhnt
wir machen dass jede woche mit mehreren
wagen
zunächst trennt das team den vier tonnen
schweren wagen aufbau von drehgestellen
wir können den wagen jetzt anheben das
machen wir in zwei etappen
die männer sind angespannt wenn die vier
hebevorrichtungen nicht exakt synchron
arbeiten könnte der wagen kippen
seit dem bereich
ok dann hoch damit
mechaniker auf beiden seiten prüfen
während des abhebens dass wirklich alle
verbindungen gelöst sind
[Musik]
nach zehn minuten ist es geschafft
das drehgestell ist wichtig für die
fahrsicherheit und das versteuert teil
das am stärksten belastet wird
wir haben die radler stelle und radsatz
lager demontiert
jetzt werden meine kollegen den wagen
reinigen die lage prüfen und die achsen
und rat der stelle per ultraschall
untersuchen
morgen bauen wir den wagen zusammen und
er kann wieder den dienst auf der
schiene antreten
dann wird man sich ghettos und sein team
dem nächsten wagen
gegen 16 uhr beginnt die abendlichen
rush-hour
zehntausende pendler wollen über die
station komsomolskaja zu den umliegenden
fernbahnhöfen
auf dem bahnsteig herrscht erneut reges
rein
obama muss nun wieder besonders
aufpassen
morgens sind die leute aus geholt jetzt
am nachmittag sind sie müde von der
arbeit
die stoßzeit am nachmittag zieht sich
auch länger als am morgen weil nicht
alle zur gleichen zeit feierabend haben
sie konzentriert sich auf die
rolltreppen das nadelöhr der
metrostation
ich lasse jetzt zwei rolltreppen
aufwärts fangen
meine kollegen halten die leute kurz auf
damit wir die laufrichtung ändern kann
dann müssen die fahrgäste durch die
station der soko nietzsches car linie
hierher kommen
die rolltreppen sind ein wichtiges
hilfsmittel um den strom der fahrgäste
zu regeln
die spätestens 29 nach wir warten noch
eine minute dann machen wir zu nicht
früher pünktlich zur halben stunde wie
besprochen
die fahrtrichtung der rolltreppe lässt
sich in nur 20 sekunden ändern
genau wie ihre kollegen am morgen macht
sich jetzt auch yoga die tatsache
zunutze dass die beiden metrostationen
an diesem verkehrsknotenpunkt über
durchgänge verbunden sind sie ändert die
fahrtrichtung der zweiten rolltreppe so
dass die fahrgäste nun schneller aus der
station herauskommen wer rein will muss
jetzt allerdings einen umweg durch die
angrenzende station der roten linie
nehmen
[Musik]
trotzdem bilden sich vor den rolltreppen
lange schlangen kein ort für
klaustrophobischer
alle 90 sekunden hätten züge und
entlassen bis zu 1000 fahrgäste in die
station
bis zum ende der abendlichen rush-hour
kommen fast 25.000 menschen hier durch
[Musik]
kurz vor 20 uhr
over to you buzz arbeitstag geht zu ende
in einer kurzen übergabe informiert sie
ihre kollegin was für die nachtschicht
ansteht dem regulären reinigungsarbeiten
werden auch mehrere technische
inspektionen an den schienen
durchgeführt
ich habe noch keine pläne ich stehe
jetzt erst mal nach hause und dann sehe
ich weiter
bei der arbeit bin ich nie müde das
merke ich immer erst wenn ich zu hause
bin
roger hat jetzt einen tag frei dann
wartet die nächste zwölf stunden schicht
auf sie
in moskau neigt sich der tag dem ende zu
die metropole kommt langsam zur ruhe
in der u bahn herrscht nur noch wenig
betrieb
[Musik]
das team für die nachtschicht steht
schon bereit um punkt ein uhr schließen
polizisten die eingänge von jetzt an
kommt niemand mehr in die metrostation
hinein
[Musik]
eine halbe stunde später verlässt der
letzte fahrgast die station wenn auch
nicht ganz freiwillig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt beseitigt das reinigungsteam die
spuren der vielen passagiere alle
stationen der moskauer metro werden jede
nacht gereinigt
station chefin riemer los sie war
bereitet die strecken wartung vor
sie wird nachts durchgeführt weil dafür
die stromschiene abgeschaltet werden
muss tagsüber undenkbar
der disponent hat uns gerade angewiesen
die strecke zu sperren
um sicherzustellen dass keine wartungs
fahrzeuge in den tunnel fahren wird er
versperrt
ein team von technikern hat jetzt drei
stunden zeit um die schienen im bereich
der station zu überprüfen und alle
notwendigen wartungsarbeiten
durchzuführen
[Musik]
wir testen jetzt ob das alarmsystem an
der tunneleinfahrt funktioniert
in jeder tunneleinfahrt sind sensoren
auf die exakte breite der züge
eingestellt
wird beispielsweise jemand in der zugtür
eingeklemmt und mitgeschleift lösen sie
sofort einen alarm aus
[Musik]
die station chefin muss das system jede
nacht prüfen
funktioniert einwandfrei
fünf uhr morgens alle arbeiten sind
erledigt
wir sind fertig fahrgäste können kommen
schon 30 minuten später öffnen sich die
türen zum moskauer metro erneut
und für europas meistbefahrene s u bahn
netz beginnt ein neuer verkehrs reichert
akt
[Musik]